[Music]
christmas time is my favorite time and
that's because mail's here mail's here
you get christmas cards yay
hi mr mailman hi amber oh
my god i got so many christmas cards for
you oh wow thank you
yeah
and then tarik i got a lot for you too
wowie zowie oh thanks mr mailman
oh
hey amber yeah what are you gonna do for
christmas me
for christmas
what won't i do
[Music]
i'm gonna eat a lot of food i'm gonna
hang out on my couch i'm gonna watch a
ton of christmas movies
that's what i'm gonna do this christmas
what are you gonna do tarek me
well
i'm gonna go see mom and dad
i'm gonna wrap a bunch of gifts and
every year we all watch die hard
[Music]
that's what i'm gonna do for
hey what about you mr mailman what are
you gonna do for christmas me well
thanks for asking
work
what
work i'm gonna work this christmas
oh okay well at least you get time and a
half nope double time no just regular
time okay
uh sorry to hear that i mean work is
work
say that yep yeah oh hey amber uh what
are you gonna eat on christmas me oh boy
what won't i eat
[Music]
i'm gonna have bacon and greens i'm
gonna have a big gold juicy ham
i'm gonna have macaroni and cheese
that's what i'm gonna eat on christmas
how about you tarek me oh buddy
[Music]
i'm gonna have every kind of pie
i'm gonna have every kind of cake
and it'll all be
topped with whipped cream
that's what i'm gonna eat on christmas
hey mr mailman what about you what are
you going to eat on christmas me huh
thanks for asking
yogurt
what
did you say gogurt yeah my favorite but
you work so hard your big treat is
gogurt yeah i mean on christmas i'll
still be working i can't exactly sit
down and eat wait there's no mail
delivery on christmas i'll be working my
third job
third job yes i bake cookies at the
local bakery oh great just eat some of
those that's not allowed jesus
i have to ask please don't what's your
second job i'm a telemarketer yeah
uh
hey amber what
what's your wish for this new year oh i
can't wait to tell you bud
my wish for the new year
is to fill hearts with good cheer to let
my loved ones all be happy
that's what i wish for new years
so tarek what's your wish oh simple
my wish for the new year is to fill
hearts with goodwill and to have peace
in my community
that's what i wish for new year's hey mr
millman tarek don't
mr mailman what is your i have to know
i want to be happy i know
mr mailman yeah
what
is your wish for new year oh
my wish for the new year wowie zowie
that's easy
sucks oh
it's so sad
i mean don't feel sad feel motivated to
do something about wealth inequality
oh
you know what
you know what mr mailman you're right
and we we have to elect people who
care and support organizations that
bring about actual change yeah thank you
tarek and thank you mr mailman uh i i
made a tip uh but okay go off i guess
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you